Lindsay starts off this hour in Maryland
hi Lindsay welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show and I have a year better than I
deserve what's up in your world okay so
I'm 29 years old and I'm 137 thousand
dollars in debt
yeah so a part of that consists of my
car amount and the other part is my
student loans my rental car agent I make
forty five to three thousand dollars a
year and I still live at home with my
parents so I want to move out I might
get this debt paid off and how much how
much do you owe on your car
seventeen thousand okay it's an awfully
big car payment for a income like yours
a mess like you got yeah well I was just
involved in the car accident and so my
car was totaled
back in December so I had to get another
one so that car that was totaled
actually was almost paid off had like
seven thousand dollars left so why did
you have to upgrade didn't you moved up
in car you have a nicer car than the one
that was totaled one night exactly they
were both missing price actually then
where'd the money go because you said
you only owed 7,000 now you're 17 the
car was in the accident and it was
totaled I know they gave you a check
when that happens right and it's like
what was the car worth the new one no
the one that got totaled when I got
photos it was $17,000 it was worth that
much but then when the accident occurred
I had like seven thousand seven dollars
left the payoff right which was know
what I mean you would have $10,000 in
your hand
they paid the car off with most of it no
honey if you get a $17,000 check and you
have a $7,000 worth of that you end up
with ten oh no no no the the check they
gave me was $10,000 after they paid your
car off no no before they paint the cost
of your car
was not worth 17 your car was worth 10
maybe I'm confused by your question okay
you bought it you had a $10,000 car now
you bought a $17,000 car or a $20,000
car you went up in caller you had to
otherwise you would still owe $7,000
well when my old car got paid off with
the settlement check I was only left
with $3,000 which means they valued your
old car at $10,000 do you understand
okay and then you went and bought a car
for $20,000 right yes and then the 3,000
knocked it down for 17,000 yeah so you
doubled your car when you got a car
totaled that was not necessary you could
have got on the bottom of the $10,000
car that was what I was trying to
explain to you okay okay but anyway you
got an awful big car payment for
somebody making 45,000 with 137 thousand
dollars in debt total the rest of this
our student loans $120,000 and student
loan debt
yes and what's your degree in business
administration and Human Resources
gotcha and you're 29 years old and then
you're living at home still and trying
to get this mess cleaned up let's
appreciate where you are okay and you're
working 40 hours a week right
between 45 and 50 hours okay all right I
think you're gonna pick up a side hustle
because you need some more money to get
after this it's gonna take you a long
time with 45,000 as a ratio against 137
and I probably would sell your car and
move down to about a $7,000 car instead
of a $20,000 car and get your debt done
away with or almost done away with on
the car and and then I would work extra
anything I can get where I'm making some
bucks because a couple thousand bucks a
month 1,500 bucks a month but change
this scenario dramatically because you
are in a mess and you're gonna have to
work like you're in a mess and and it's
not gonna be pleasant and if you can
stay in that home for another year and
work and make an extra 1,500 a month on
a side hustle of some kind and throw and
move down in car and throw everything at
this I think you can get a good run at
starting to knock off the debt but
you're gonna have to live on nothing and
you're not gonna go out and party you're
not gonna have time you're gonna be
working all the time and you can't
afford to go out but if you don't have
any rent and you don't have any utility
bills that's also going to help you
big-time move towards this debt and so I
would prescribe no life work all the
time throw all your money at this debt
and move down in car and stay at home
for at least one more year hopefully
only one more you're not gonna be out of
debt in one year but you can make some
real headway on it doing that I mean if
you could reduce this debt thirty
thousand bucks in the next 12 months
plus move down in car ten that'd be
forty thousand I think that's very
doable and that would be put you in a
completely different mindset about this
debt you'd be only under a hundred at
that point and I think that's where
it'll get you to so good question hold
on I'm gonna send you a copy of the book
the Total Money Makeover to help you and
show you what I'm talking about it'll
help you unfold on that open phones a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let me tell you 25 years of doing
this show thirty years of doing this
show the number of times that people
call me like she did and your car got
totaled and you move up in car is almost
every time and in the hilarious thing is
the Bible says how the abundance of the
heart the mouth speaks and so the words
you use tell us how deceived you are
inside of you okay here's how deceived
you are I had to buy a new car because
my car got totaled and that's your
explanation and that was hers and I'm
not putting her down I'm not running her
down she's great we're gonna help her
okay
but when your car gets totaled you don't
buy a more expensive car than the one
you were driving as a matter of fact it
could be a real opportunity to buy a
less expensive car than the one you were
driving
here's an example in her case let's use
her case okay she was driving a $10,000
car she at $7,000 on insurance company
gave her a $10,000 check what should she
have done by a $3,000 car no car payment
ah did she bought a $20,000 car and the
reason she bought the $20,000 cars
because her car got totaled no it's not
he's just about 20,000 our cars cuz she
won 20,000 our car and she doubled the
amount of car that she had but that's
almost everybody that calls me when
their car gets totaled they always move
up and the weight is there's something
about the way our brain gets in a fog
and we're like okay the car got totaled
that means thank you and I have an
excuse I have a rationalization to move
up in car and then I had to buy a car
because my car got towed yeah well why
not one you have to buy a $3,000 car
with the cash in your pocket after your
rivers got paid off
that's move down in car and pay cash
when your car gets totally could be a
blessing if you don't rationalize your
butt off and move up in car and and it's
so foggy we can't even get through the
math on it we can't get to you it's just
but boy I see that all most every time
so if your car gets totaled
what you need to say is thank you Jesus
and pay cash for a little tiny beater
car I love it